- Une nette majorité
le projet de constitution
qui leur a été soumis.
Exceptionnellement, le vote
était obligatoire, ce qui
explique la grande.
15 millions de Chiliens
devaient approuver ou rejeter
un projet de constitution
rédigé par une convention
la société civile.
Il s'ag Il s'ag Il s'agissait r
la vieille constitution
de la dictature Pinochet,n frein
à la justice sociale,en privilée
économique néo-libérale
profondément inégae de 170 page,
388 articles qui voulaient
enchâsser un nombre
impressionnant de droits
à la sa
publiques, à des retraites
et des logements décents,
le droit
Les Autochtones, en particulier
le peuple Mapuche contestataire,
auraient été reconnus commenati.
Le gouvernement de Gabriel
Boric, qui a voté à Punta Arenas
à l'extrême sudétait sur la sel.
NIBALDO MOSCIATTI OLIVIERI, dir.
de rédaction, Radio Bío Bío
- C'est un gouvernement
trop de la constitution.
Alors pas mal de votants vontnt
voter non pour la constitution,
mais vont voter s'ils approuvent
gouvernement.
- Trop et trop vitpays
encore très conservateur?
Quel que soit le résultat
le processus doit continuer
dans un nité.
Comme les Chiliens ont
clairement dit en 2020
dans un premier référendum
constitution, il va falloir
recommencer.
c'est une nouvelle étape
parce que ceux qui sont pour sor
l'approbation ou le rejet,
ils savent qu'ils doivent
le rejet, c'est élire
une nouvntion.
- Une autre constituante,
un consensus entre partis
Boric devra faire preuve
ation et d'habilité.
Jean-Michel Lepri